vous pensez que c'est drôle que nos océans
meurent pensez-vous que c'est drôle nous devons
faire tout ce que nous pouvons tout ce que nous pouvons
pour agir là-dessus et nous n'en faisons pas
assez
vous avez notre rôle de leadership à jouer, pas
seulement sur les plastiques marins, un domaine sur lequel
je suis heureux que ce gouvernement se
concentre enfin, nous avons un rôle de gardien de
la Grande Barrière de Corail, nous avons un
comité du patrimoine mondial de l'UNESCO qui examine l'
état du récif  au moment où nous parlons
personne ne peut nier l'impact que le climat
a eu sur les récifs du monde j'ai surfé
récemment aux Maldives 90% des
toits 90 pour cent du toit sénateur
canavan tu serais tu serais
choqué de savoir sénateur canavan ta chaise
90%  de leurs toits sont morts j'en ai été
témoin je l'ai vu nous savons que la moitié
de la barrière de corail est maintenant morte leur
plus grand organisme vivant sur cette
planète il est mort sénateur canavan regardez
cette science et ce sont des gens comme
vous qui entrent dans ce  placez et tirez
les leviers de l'industrie des combustibles fossiles
qui en sera responsable vous
serez tenu responsable par les
générations futures permettez-moi de vous assurer que ce que vous
faites se transforme en
activité criminelle vous avez des criminels climatiques si
vous continuez sur cette voie de la combustion  les
combustibles fossiles quand tous les signes avant-coureurs
sont là et que vous les mâchez, ignorez-
les, ce n'est pas acceptable, ce n'est pas
acceptable, alors je vais ramener cela à
ce que nous avons devant nous aujourd'hui, qui
est une petite demande et une contribution, vous
riez, sénateur canavan, je  j'aimerais que les caméras
puissent capturer ton visage en train de rire pendant que
le toit meurt en toi sénateur
agissant toujours comme un clown là-bas tu penses
que c'est drôle
oh c'est une chérie penses-tu que c'est
drôle oui ton corps ne me montrera pas
son génial s'il te plait reprends ta place
les interjections sont très désordonnées on
s'attend à ce que les sénateurs soient entendus en
silence et je fais en sorte que nos sénateurs
contribuant au débat ignorent
les interjections Sarah Bush était
vous